on est en face du massif de la meigge
entre la Meig le rateau et ces
différents
glaciers cette photo elle date de 1906
c'est une photo du glacier de Saren qui
est un des premiers glaciers qui a été
mesuré en France tout ça c'est de la
glace on voit juste quelques rochers qui
émergent et puis on voit même en fait
que la partie haute cette glace est
recouverte par de la neige et il y a une
même photo qui a été reprise un peu
moins de 100 ans plus tard ce glacier
même endroit donc on retrouve ces
rochers qui sort à l'époque mais là on
voit le retrait glaciaire à l'été 2023
ce glacier de la Saren a totalement
disparu il a laissé les rochers à
découvert même si la planète s'est
réchauffée d'un degré environ en 100 ans
ce phénomène de fonte n'est pas
seulement l'effet de la chaleur l'humain
est à plus de 90 % responsable du
réchauffement climatique qu'on a
aujourd'hui ces glaciers qui fondent
vont nous poser un souci par exemple
d'accès à certains cols certaines brèche
à certains endroits où avant on pouvait
traverser assez facilement en ce début
de mois d'octobre en compagnie de Pascal
Gibou guide de haute montagne et de
Lucas davaz glaciologue nous sommes
allés dans les Alpes à 2500 m d'altitude
pour observer le glacier de la Girose un
paradis pour les skieurs et les
alpinistes comme tous les glaciers du
monde la Girose fond et fragilise la
montagne la fonte de ces glaciers va
libérer des zones qui sont plus tenues
par la glace et donc qui vont être
instable on peut parler d'écroulement
rocheux ou même de déstabilisation de
certains glaciers des pierres tombent il
y a aussi des glaciers qui vont être
très raides et qui peuvent se décrocher
en lien avec le réchauffement climatique
la fondte des glaciers complique le
travail des guides ils doivent trouver
de nouveaux chemins pour atteindre les
sommets prendre garde aux crevasses aux
chutes de pierres au lave
torrentiel la fonte de la glace menace
aussi le cycle de l'eau les glaciers
sont aujourd'hui un réservoir précieux
comme nous l'a expliqué le maire de La
Grave jusqu'à présent on n pas eu de
restriction d'eau l'eau dégueule sur nos
fontaines sur nos tropleins mais là il
va falloir vraiment qu'on enem prenne
soin qu'on apprenne aux gens à
économiser l'eau en tout cas peut-être
que dans 50 ans on aura on aura plus de
glacier et là la musique va changer
parce qu'il va falloir aller chercher
l'eau je sais pas où mais il va falloir
qu'on aille chercher l'eau il faut qu'on
protège nos captages qu'on protège notre
glacier et qu'on essaie de le prolonger
le plus
[Musique]
possible nous voici au sommet bien
ensoleillé notre glacier de la Girose
c'est un glacier qui a beaucoup évolué
ces dernières années en lien avec le
réchauffement climatique toute la bande
de rocher qui est au milieu et qui est
bien visible aujourd'hui était encore
sous la glace il y a 3 4 ans quand on a
débuté les mesures sur le glacier en se
début d'automne la partie basse du
glacier de la Girose devrait déjà être
recouverte de neige celle-ci devrait
former une couche protectrice afin qu'il
se reforme pendant l'hiver ce n'est pas
le cas avec près de 20 degrés ce 9
octobre la glace risque de fondre plus
vite Lucas qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
pour protéger les glaciers aujourd'hui
pour protéger les glaciers il y a pas
énormément de solution mais en fait la
vraie solution pour limiter la forme des
glaciers ça va être de limiter nos
émissions de gaz à effet de ser pour
tâcher d'enrayer ou au moins de ralentir
le phénomène de fonte il faut diminuer
notre empreinte carbone ces dernières
années on constate que celle des
français est en baisse cette évolution
de l'empreinte carbone elle nous montre
que tout n'est pas perdu par des actions
qui nous permettent de limiter notre
emprinte carbone on peut limiter les
enjeux et les impacts associés au
réchaurant climatique la montagne reste
belle accessible disent ceux qui la
connaissent pour en prendre soin il faut
modifier notre façon de la fréquenter
pour qu' continue de faire vivre les
[Musique]
hommes alors c'était le reportage donc
de Madeleine mé Renant leslez alors ce
qu'on a pas peut-être vu tout de suite
dans le reportage c'est qu'en fait on
aurait voulu aller au sommet du du
glacier de la Girose mais alors c'est le
secret du tournage c'est qu'en fait ce
weekend là il y avait une Zade he il y
avait des activistes écologiques qui
sont montés au sommet du glacier pour
protester contre un un projet de
construction d'un troisè téléphérique
sur le le glacier de la Girose et donc
c'est pour ça qu'on allé regarder d'en
face alors je voyais que ça vousit un
peu réagir quand le le maire Marc quand
le maire de la commune de La Grave dit
qu'on va devoir aller chercher de l'eau
d'ici quelques décennies c'estd que très
concrètement ce qui se passe au sommet
de la montagne ça a un effet aussi sur
la vallée parce qu'en fait c'est des
ressources en eau disponible qui
disparaissent bien oui il va y avoir des
ressources en eau qui vont disparaître
alors peut-être avec un peu de chance
ils auront des lacs qui se formeront
mais il faudra avoir de la chance c'est
pas
obligatoire et est-ce que que qu'est-ce
qu'on va faire pour ces zones est-ce
qu'on va les protéger
et et c'est ce que souhaitent de
nombreux scientifiques ils veulent qu'
qu'on sanctuarise en faites ces zones
qui vont être déglacé oui donc c'est
qu'on va créer en fait de nouveaux
paysages qui vont apparaître qu'on va
voir apparaître sous nos yeux lorsque la
la glace va fondre c'est ça et donc la
question se pose de savoir comment
est-ce qu'on va les protéger comment
est-ce que l'homme va les appréhender
c'est ça est-ce qu'on va les protéger et
est-ce qu'on ne va pas surtout les
exploiter et trop les exploiter parce
que voilà donc c'est très important
alors je voulais aussi vous donner un
chiffre qui a fait l'actualité récemment
on a beaucoup parler moi j'ai appris à
l'école comme tout le monde que le
Montblanc mesure 4810 m c'est la mesure
souvent qu'on apprend dans les manuels
de géographie alors il y a une équipe
qui all les mesurer et très exactement
he ce sont des géomètres qui ont essayé
de faire une mesure de la hauteur du
Mont Blanc qui disent non il fait
4805 m et quelques dizaines de
centimètres alors ça cette mesure
apparemment elle ferait elle ser ser de
2 m inférieur à la précédente qui avait
été faite en en 2021 est-ce qu'elle
signifie vraiment quelque chose et
comment est-ce que scientifiquement on
peut l'appréhender non elle signifie
rien sur sur 2 ans pour avoir une
évolution précise il faut avoir
l'évolution sur des dizaines d'années
euh et des mesures très précises qui
soient totalement incontestables là les
mesures ne sont pas tout à fait précises
et la méthode de mesure qui a été
utilisée C C année mais légèrement
différent de celle qui avait été utilisé
il y a 2 ans d'accord c'est-à-dire
concrètement euh c'est-à-dire que là ils
ont fait ce qu'ils appellent une
photogramétrie c'estàd qu'ils ont pris
plein de points et ils ont survolé la
zone avec un drone ils ont fait des
mesures pendant une heur et ils
ont regardé ces mesures par rapport à
des
satellites des différentes constellation
GPS Galileo et autres et après ils ont
recalculé la mesure il y a 2 ans bah il
y avait pas la photogrammétrie et plein
de points on avait fait juste une mesure
pendant une heure environ donc il faut
avoir aussi des méthodes qui soient les
mêmes 2 ans enfin à chaque à chaque
mesure ça une continuité dans ouais dans
les méthodes de alors justement vous
vous êtes pas géomètre vous êtes
glaciologue vous vous occupez de
l'évolution vous regardez l'évolution du
climat concrètement bah ce qui permet de
penser de comprendre l'évolution dans
les 10 20 30 prochaines années glcier
notamment de montagne donc sont des
outils des calculs beaucoup plus pointus
comment est-ce que vous arrivez
exactement à modéliser cette évolution
gar crener alors on peut modéliser un
seul glacier quand on s'y intéresse ou
le tous les glaciers du monde le
problème avec tous les glaciers du monde
c'est qu'il y en a beaucoup euh donc il
y a des des des modèles il faut beaucoup
de données pour savoir quelle est
l'exposition du glacier sa géométrie et
son climat et cetera donc il y a dans le
monde une petite dizaine de de groupes
de recherche qui qui ont ce genre de de
de gros modèles numériques qui prennent
en compte le climat la géométrie des
glaciers qui qui calculle ensuite
l'évolution des glaciers individuels
dans le monde entier et qui font des des
des résumés sur sur sur le globe et puis
qui compare ces modèles et qui nous
donne des évolutions futures projetées
de des glaciers et alors on lit parfois
des choses effrayantes que c'est je
crois que c'est vos collègues même de
l'IG qui disent que en
2050 les tr/4 à peu près des glaciers
dans les Alpes auront probablement
disparu et dans les Pyrénées alors là
c'est encore plus radical c'est
l'ensemble des glaciers des pyrénés qui
auront complètement fondu ça c'est ceux
à qui on se prépare en 2050 alors les
glaciers qui vont disparaître en premier
c'est les tout petits évidemment dans
les dans les pyrinées ils sont très
petits dans les Alpes il y en a quelques
grands mais il y en a aussi beaucoup de
petits et de manière globale dans le
Glob sur la terre entière c'est dans les
régions où les glaciers sont petits qui
vont disparaître en premier donc les
Alpes en font font parti et quand on
parle les 3/4 c'est surtout les les les
tout petits le plus grand des Alpes le
glacier de la leche il va encore rester
plus longtemps mais c'est eux qui
contribuent évidemment le plus à
l'augmentation niveau de la mer ensuite
alors Marx qui est un peu désespérant
aussi dans le reportage qu'on a entendu
c'est que on entend bien les
glaciologues l'expliquer à nos reporter
on a l'impression que de toute façon
quoi qu'on fasse les glaciers dont
Gérard kner parle à l'instant sont
condamnés c'estàdire que même si
aujourd'hui par quel miracle je ne sais
pas mais si on arrivait à à stopper
toutes nos émissions de carbone on est
de toute façon sur une trajectoire qui
va amener les glaciers alpins à fondre
quoi qu'il arrive ah oui alors ça c'est
très intéressant d'ailleurs parce que à
peu près tous les modèles de prévision
disent jusqu'à 2040 peu importe les
évolutions de gaz fait quoi qu'on fasse
hein quoi qu'on fasse ils vont fondre
voilà alors après on peut peut-être
préserver quelques uns qui sont très
haut c'est aussi ceux qui sont les plus
élevés ceux qui ont enfin qui ont une
grande d'altitude qui auront une petite
chance de subsister hein dans quelques
dizaines d'années donc effectivement
c'est c'est catastrophique et même pour
les mesures c'est compliqué enfin
euh mais on en parlera peut-être tout à
l'heure mais il y a le projet ice memory
ouis qui est très intéressant pour
essayer d'aller documenter les glaces et
euh les dernières missions depuis 3 4
ans euh ben ils ont des problèmes à
aller faire des des regarder ce qu'il y
a dans la glace quoi alors ce qui je
peux intervenir là-dessus euh les
glaciers ont un temps de réaction
aujourd'hui avec le climat qu'on a ils
fondent donc ils ont euh un un bilan de
masse qu'on dit négatif et donc si on
stabilise la température le climat au
niveau d'aujourd'hui il continue à
fondre parce que euh leur leur leur là
où ils sont il fait trop chaud pour être
la pour être de la glace et donc après
ils vont disparaître à aux régions où
ils sont aujourd'hui remonter euh il y a
que que les parties les plus hautes qui
vont rester et se stabiliser mais ça
prend du temps pour un petit glacier
c'est quelques années pour un plus grand
glacier c'est 20 et parfois une centaine
d'années pour les grands glaciers
polaires c'est de là que vient le fait
que même si on stabilise le climat
aujourd'hui ils continueront à fondre on
verra l'émergence un signal de de de
retard ou de de de ralentissement de de
la fonte seulement au bout de 20 30 40
ans parce que on parle des glaciers on
était dans les Alpes mais les la fondte
des glaciers que ce soit dans l'épaule
ou en haute montagne pour vous c'est des
phénomènes qui se ressemblent qui qui se
rapproche scientifiquement dans
l'observation ou faites des différences
bah un glacier c'est un glacier qui soit
dans les Alpes ou dans les région
polaire ou en Antarctique après certains
processus sont un peu différents parce
que certains processus sont plus
importants dans les glaciers très froids
que dans les glaciers chauds mais
effectivement ça ça reste le même alors
g j'entendais aussi Marc utiliser tout à
l'heure une expression qui m'a intéressé
Marc vous disez avec un peu de chance
c'estàdire que vous vous faites des
modèles dans un modèle vous n'intégrez
pas ou alors j' imagine difficilement ce
qui relève de la chance alors qu'est-ce
qu'on ne maîtrise pas qu'est-ce qu'on
qu'est-ce qu'on ne sait pas encore
exactement modéliser quelles sont un peu
les les variables qui peuvent faire
changer les choses je sais pas par
exemple est-ce qu'on arrive à estimer
qu'elle va être le niveau de de
pluviométrie dans les 10 20 ou 30
prochaines années dans les glaciers
est-ce que ça change la façon de
modéliser l'évolution de la de la glace
en altitude et comment surtout est-ce
que vous arrivez à intégrer tous ces
paramètres qui par définition sont pas
forcément tous extrêmement prévisibles
alors pour les projections futures c'est
pour ça qu'on l'appelle projection et
pas pr idiction il y a il y a surtout le
scénario d'émission de gaz effet de
serre nous moi en tant que physicien
j'ai pas de boule de cristal je peux pas
savoir quel vont t les émission de gaz à
effet de ser futur donc on est obligé de
faire des hypothèses plusurs scénarios
travaille sur différents scénarios c'est
pour ça qu'on appelle ça des projection
donc première incertitude c'est le
scénario futur scénario qu'on va dire
optimiste ou pessimisteilà on en prend
plus selon les les discussions qu'on va
avoir notamment dans la prochaine COP
est-ce qu'on va réussir à vraiment
partir sur une bonne trajectoire ou
voilà donc ça c'est une première s
incertitude très importante surtout
quand on regarde dans l'avenir plus
lointain à l'horizon 2050 2100 enfin
au-delà de 2050 euh après une autre
source d'incertitude c'est notre
connaissance imparfaite des connaiss des
des des conditions dans chacun des
glaciers les glaciers sont très
variables vous allez dans les ales vous
avez des grands des petits des des face
nord face sud différentes géométries et
cetera c'est mal connu on connaît pas
les épaisseurs des glaciers et cetera
exactement partout donc ça c'est une
autre source incertitude euh la
représentation qu'on en fait
mathématique elle est pas parfaite on
travaille dessus c'est pour ça que je
suis encore payé pour travailler sur le
climat c'est parce qu'on ne sait pas
encore tout euh et ce genre de choses
donc des processus qui sont pas pris en
compte les les poussières qui tombent
dessus sont mal mal pris en compte et
cetera donc il y a il y a pas mal de
sources d'incertitude évidemment le
climat en fait partie aussi il y a des
des des une évolution du climat sur une
dizaine une une vingtaine d'années c'est
essentiellement euh beaucoup de de de
c'est la météo si vous voulez enfin
c'est on sait pas exactement prédire
quel va quel va être le l'hiver l'année
prochaine s'il va être plutôt plus
neigeux ou pas ça ça on sait pas il peut
y avoir c'est partie de toutes les voilà
toutes les hypothèses que vous intégrez
dans dans vos
scénarios alors justement cette
variabilité du climat à court terme on
on va la on on va l'appréhender en
faisant plusieurs simulations en prenant
plusieurs modèles qui font des des des
évolutions différentes du climat et
comme ça on on a une idée sur
l'incertitude donc il y a des
incertitudes par contre ce qu'on sait
comme Marc l'a dit les 20 prochaines
années jusqu'en 2050 à peu près la
moitié des de la masse des glaciers
alpins va disparaître et les 3/4 des
glaciers parce que c'est surtout les
petits qui sont nombreux mais qui vont
disparaître en premier alors Marc je
vous entendez parler donc dans dans
toutes ces hypothèses dans tous ces
scénarios de toute façon il y a cette
certitude c'est que les paysages que
nous avons connus que tous les
passionnés de montagne voient
aujourd'hui quand il monent dans les
Alpes se transforment et donc vous
accouchez de de nouveaux paysages de
nouvelles morphologies dans les
montagnes et là ce que vous dites c'est
très intéressant c'est que on sait pas
encore comment est-ce que comment est-ce
que les hommes vont réagir comment
est-ce qu'ils vont vouloir se les
approprier est-ce qu'on va chercher à
les protéger ou au contraire à les
exploiter et c'est là justement aussi
que les scientifiques essayent de traer
de réfléchir de dire bah de toute façon
les glaciers vont fondre et vont laisser
à découvert d'autres choses qu'est-ce
qu'on fait maintenant de ces nouveaux
paysages qui vont qui vont éclore oui
parce que il va peut-être y avoir des
par exemple des forêts primaires qui
vont réapparaître des et il y aura des
forêts sous les glaciers bah peut-être
qu'il y aura des forêts qui vont en tout
cas se développer sous les enfin à
l'endroit où il y avait des glaciers
euh faudra attendre un moment hein oui
il va falloir attendre va falloir
attendre un peu de temps mais avec un
peu de chance hein ça va pouvoir
permettre à des mélaises par exemple de
monter mais ça va prendre effectivement
du temps euh euh que ce genre de chose
se se développe euh par ailleurs pour il
y aura des fleurs aussi et pour toute la
biodiversité ça pourra avoir un effet
parce que par exemple il y aura des des
des insectes qui pourront aller butiner
en hauteur parce que les fleurs qui sont
un petit peu plus bas par exemple ne
pourront pas survivre avec une
température plus haute donc on va avoir
une espèce de déplacement comme ça
probable
de de cette biodiversité vers le haut
c'est la végétation va remonter on
connaitt tous l'image de l' c'est ce
qu'on pense c'est ce qu'on pense qu'on
pense c'est ce qu'on pense et c'est ce
qu'on espère et euh et si ça se produit
euh et bien il faudra préserver ces
zones hein il faut préserver ces zones
et en même temps il y a un objectif pour
euh préserver la biodiversité mondiale
c'est d'avoir 30 % des terres et des
mers qui soient sauvegardé protégé euh
c'està-dire on concrètement on peut pas
y aller par exemple on pe exploite pas
voilà et euh et bien ces zoneslà
pourraient constituer euh une chance en
fait pour atteindre cet objectif de 30 %
en 2040 h voilà c'est trouver un un bien
sur un mal quoi enfin sur un un problème
catastrophique non je sais pas qu'est-ce
que euh oui oui tout à fait c'est
scientifiquement c'est un problème
intéressant de savoir voilà il y a des
zones qui se qui se dégagent bon après
d'abord ça va être des cailloux pour les
écologues ça doit être extrêmement
intéressant de voir comment la
succession des espèces s'installent
l'écosystème un écosystème nouveau
s'installe effectivement ça peut être
extrêmement intéressant en revanche il y
a quelque chose qui disparaît pour le
coup avec la glace et qu'on ne
retrouvera plus quand elle aura
complètement fondu c'est ce que vous
disiez hein c'est que la glace c'est
aussi une formidable mémoire du climat
en fait c'est quasiment une banque
d'archive historique hein c'est un peu
ça quand on creuse pour faire une
carotte de glace et que les
scientifiques s'y intéressent alors vous
allez nous dire un peu comment
évidemment parce que c'est pas forcément
compréhensible pour le commun des
mortels mais la la carotte de glace
prélevée permet de dire toute l'histoire
de l'évolution du climat depuis des
milliers des milers d'anné c'est ça
alors ce qui se passe c'est c'est très
simple si vous avez un glacier qui
surtout un glacier dans une région
froide où ça fond pas bah chaque année
il y a de la nouvelle neige qui se
dépose donc cette neige elle elle elle
c'est de l'eau essentiellement mais elle
contient aussi d'autres éléments
chimique et cetera et puis la neige
quand elle s'accumule petit à petit sur
notamment sur un calotte de glace ou sur
un glassier en Hare altitude mais elle
se transforme en neige en glace ensuite
et la glace en fait c'est euh la neige
comprimée sauf qu'il y a des bulles
d'air dedans et ces bulles d'air
contiennent des informations extrêmement
intéressantes on peut retrouver l'air du
passé avec ça il y a d'autres analyses
on va pas rentrer dans les détails
l'isotopees de l'eau qui nous donne
l'information sur la température du
passé et cetera donc c'est extrêmement
précieux la condition est évidemment
c'est qu'il y a pas trop de fonte ou pas
de fonte en été parce que si vous avez
de la fonte en été vous avez de l'eau
qui percolle et ça vous fout en l'air
tout votre signal pour toute votre belle
stratification comme on dit euh avec le
temps parce que quand vous avez la neige
qui s'accumule gentiment en creusant
vous remontez dans le temps et c'est ça
le principe de ces forages sur les
glaciers et dans les surtout dans les
carottes de glace dans les calottes de
glace en Antarctique et au grenlande on
peut remonter jusqu'à 800000 ans et et
c'est ce que vous dites justement sur
l'altération de cette mémoire de la
glace c'est que bah on l'a vu une
expédition au Svalbard récemment ce qui
sont allés voir quand ils ont
concrètement fait leur leur forage leur
carrotage c'est que bah effectivement la
mémoire avait été altérée par la fonte
par la fonte des glaciers et ça du coup
ça détériore tout le matériau
scientifique à disposition c'est
évidemment une catastrophe pour ceux qui
observent précisément ce que nous a
expliqué garade crinire vraiment cette
mémoire du passé climatique ah oui c'est
une catastrophe bah c'est une
catastrophe parce que on espère trouver
quelque chose qui soit complètement gelé
et là ils espéraient creuser par exemple
auvbard à 150 m à peu près et à 80 m ils
ont trouvé de l'eau donc à 80 m de
profondeur sous la glace 80 m sous la
glace oui ils ont trouvé de l'eau donc
donc à 85 m je crois et donc ils se sont
déplacés ils sont allés dans d'autres
endroits
et et
les voilà ce qu'ils ont récupéré n'est
pas forcément de très bonne qualité mais
bon ils disent que ça a été un succès
donc on va attendre d'avoir les
résultats scientifiques pour savoir si
ça a été un succès et si on arrive à
remonter le film du climat dans cette
région hein parce que ce qu'il y a de
très intéressant c'est dans chaque
endroit où on va faire les forage et
récupérer ses carottes on a un peu la la
mémoire spécifique de la région alors il
y aura des événements mondiaux qui
auront des incidences hein mais on aura
aussi une mémoire locale donc c'est pour
ça que ce projet ice memory essae de
documenter l'ensemble des glaciers du
monde pour avoir des la mémoire du
climat dans plein d'endroits donc l'idée
c'est de se dépêcher aussi de récupérer
le plus vite possible des échantillons
qui sont encore de bonne qualité sont
encore exploitables même si on sait pas
encore forcément les faire parler tout
de suite en disant mais à l'avenir
peut-être que les scientifiques seront
contents de pouvoir travailler sur ces
échantillons là quand eux n'auront plus
accès forcément à cette à une glace
deussi bonne qualité c'est ça on le fait
depuis longtemps les forages en
Antarctique qui sont faits donc on
récupère ce qu'on appelle ces carottes
ces gros cylindres de de glace depuis
très longtemps ils mettent une partie à
côté donc en Antarctique c'est très bien
etateur attend ça il y a pas besoin de
le mettre au congélateur en l'Antartique
il fait Mo 5 50 en moyenne annuelle à
l'endroitù on a fait ce forage européen
en été il fait - 20 30 ça fond pas donc
il suffit de la stocker à petit peu de
profondeur pour éviter que que le soleil
tape dessus et puis c'est bien donc
c'est un excellent congélateur et un
excellent une excellente archive
d'ailleurs beaucoup de ces forages
patrimoine qu'on fait actuellement sur
les différents glaciers du monde ben le
projet c'est de les envoyer en
Antarctique là on est sûr que ça va pas
dégeler c'est que tous les forages
glacies qu'on va faire par partout dans
le monde on va les stocker au même
endroit en que pas tous mais ceux qui
sont dans ce programme de de forage
patrimoine bah ils vont être envoyé en
l'Antarctique d'accord et donc en
espérant qu' sont en train d'être
construits pour stocker ça dans cette
zone ou il fait in 50 quoi mais donc ça
ça doit être fait dans dans un an ou
deux enfin c'est l'objectif he c'est de
les envoyer là-bas dans un an ou deux
parce queussi les méthodes alors ils
sont utilisés et lu alors ça prend pas
mal de temps à arriver à à remonter et à
lire à l'intérieur des bulles de gaz
mais on les stock aussi parce que les
techniques vont peut-être évoluer et on
aura peut-être d'autres méthodes
d'autres approches et qui permettront
d'avoir d'autres informations sur le la
mémoire passée ça c'est et c'est une
banque de données qu'on garde pour aussi
les chercheurs du
futur pour aujourd'hui aussi he et pour
le futur c'est ça qui est intéressant
d'accord oui donc c'est aussi cette
mémoire glaciaire qui est menacée quand
on quand on regarde le phénomène de la
des glaciers c'est vrai qu'on on se dit
ça a des conséquences pour les habitants
aujourd'hui tout de suite mais ça a des
conséquences aussi scientifiques au long
terme oui ben les conséquences pour les
habitants sont plus importants que pour
les
scientifiques bon ben écoutez il me
reste plus qu'à vous remercier merci
cher Marc merci garard kener d'avoir
participé à cette émission cette
première sur sur Terre des Hommes vos
décryptages vos analyses nous ont permis
bah de mieux comprendre les phénomènes à
l'œuvre de comprendre aussi les les